allegiant stadium filled with state of
the art technology whether it be
football or any other sport
concerts or conventions it has it all
but it also has some of the best chefs
cooking up surprises
on game day sports director chris
matthews got the assignment of the day
he's live from allegiant
with more on today's taste of allegiant
stadium
well thank you very much brian i haven't
had a chance yet to taste any of the
food here but i'll tell you what
it looks really really good i am here
with the president of the raiders mr
mark mcdaniel
mark you walk around here and you see
this and you're saying what is that
really stadium food
that's a good observation chris we
obviously wanted to have your standard
stadium fair which you'll see but
vegas has high expectations and vegas is
a culinary experience like no other
in the world and the stadium should
match that so you'll see that as you
walk around you'll see
some incredible selection and incredible
variety of product
you know when you seize this stadium
food kind of tell us how important it is
to have
a nice quality stadium concessionaire
and food at a facility like this
the days of going to a stadium and
getting just a hot dog and a beer
while that can be part of the experience
people have a higher expectation and
the food experience in this city and the
food experience at this stadium has to
match that has to over deliver
so we were very cognizant of that we
made sure that we had
a wide selection in in all of the
different stands all over the building
the 100 level 200 level 300 level
so if you're coming game after game you
can have a different experience every
single time you come here
and we want to make sure that you have
that option and you have the premium
option as well as your standard option
you know you talk about the food but
also the drinks here charles woodson
hall of famer
he's here you brought him out and he's
in the wine business and being very
successful
charles developed his love for wine when
he was a raider at training camp up in
napa and when he's
when he told us that he was getting in
the wine business we obviously knew
that's a tough
tough industry to break into and he
really approached it with the same
ferocity that he had on the field and
he's built an incredible brand an
incredible label and he's also getting
into the whiskey business and
you'll be able to sample all this
product here at legion stadium and we're
just proud that
we have another raider as part of the
program all right mark thank you very
much i appreciate you joining us once
again here
uh great time out here taste of
allegiant our photographers coming up
here
this is going to be a fabulous i think
you were saying there's already six
events over the next seven weeks or
something like that there's going to be
i believe 17 events over the next 16
weeks
most of most we've announced some were
finalizing but this place is going to be
busy and this city is ready for it and
we're ready to open it and show the
world
all right there is mr mark bedan the
president of the raiders